こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
ということでここはあることを
するためだけのために作られた
特殊なスタジオなんですけども
今から
僕の家じゃ出来ないような
ドッキリを特殊なスタジオを使って
していこうと思います
だけどパッと見たぶん
普通のお家っぽいスタジオ
なんですけども
ちょっと小綺麗な
えー
この部屋にはいくつかの仕掛けが
あるんですけども
今回使う仕掛けはこちら
実は
この天井が開くようになっています
今から僕と対談するつもりで
あるYouTuberが
この部屋に来ます
対談しますって言って
Googleの方が来ますって言って
待っている間に
僕と彼が座って話している間に
女の人が落ちてくるドッキリを
していきたいと思います
という感じですので
照明もうまいことちょっと停電してる感もだしつつ
やっていくので
彼なら多分良いリアクションを
してくれると思います！
本人の方を待ちましょう
ちなみに落下するタイミングは
僕が頭をかいた瞬間です
（BGM）
あはっはっはっはは
あっはっはははは
あっはっははははははは
なになに？
あっはっははははっは
そういう海外用のスタジオらしいよ
一旦呼んでくるので少々おまちくださーい
なになに？
何でおれを呼んでくれるんですか～
いやっ俺も知らないもん
ないないないないないない
えぇ～いやいやいやいやいや
いやいやいやいやいや
やっだｗｗｗ
やっだｗｗ
やばいｗ
大丈夫だよほらｗ
ほらぁ～怪しいもん
だって俺がたったら座らしてくるｗ
それはだってあやしいだって
まじでほんとに
やばいよこれ
なんてことしてくれてるんですかｗ
いや、ほんとにｗ
ちゃんとまったほうがいいよ
絶対もっと違う人と対談したほうがｗ
小粒とか.. 味がこうさ..
凝縮するからw
そしたら小粒代表でw
ねえ怖い怖い
大丈夫
ねえほんとに
ちょっとぉ～ｗ
おーーーいｗ
イヤーでも大成功大成功
ええええ
どっきり大成功
大丈夫？
めっちゃ変わりましたね
えっあれ？
あっ！ちょっと
僕8月で25なんですよ
初めて会った時って
２０とかでしょ？
２０ですね
も～やばいよ～
うわぁ！
つるつる！
やばくね？それどうすんの？
うぁぁああ～！
なになになに！？
うわぁっ！
え！？え！？
なに？
なになになに？
テ↑テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑テ↓テ↑
テ～♪テテテーテ♪
なんか　やってみたいこととかないんすか？
映ｇ…
へっくしょん！！
映画？
無理ですね。
無理って…ｗｗｗ
なんか
お休みの日とか何食べてるんですか？
お休みの日？
忙しそうなんすよね
おやすみかぁ～
いや、でも最近
忙しくて
やすみたいな～ってのは
思いっ…
あっ、
お休みの日は？
おやすっ、ｗｗ
ｗｗｗ